[Music]
[Music]
someone died since Micra has been around
for 35 years his contest a runny
lipstick in that time it's evolved from
a boxy supermini to a cute ladies car to
a plain vanilla but the fifth
generations micro morphus takes on
Nissan's current trademark contoured
look Wallflower no more
the Nissan Micra has taken on a daring
design with a low v-shaped radiator
grille suelto headlights a striking
rising Beltline and a flat roof the rear
door handles are hidden in the c-pillar
the rear looks more like a compact than
a subcompact
[Music]
roni is thrilled that a diesel engine is
once again available for the Micra the
fourth generation didn't have one but
the fifth generation offers a 1.5 litre
diesel made by Renault it produces 66
kilowatts and 220 Newton meters of
torque this Sun offers three engines for
the new Micra two gasoline powered and
one diesel which we're testing the micro
rolls off the Renault assembly line and
flower France the base model is for just
under 13,000 euros in Germany oddly
enough the start/stop system comes only
at a surcharge for all the engines but
with a few extras this little car is
near the low-priced end of the larger
compact class by default Rani is
impressed with the micro suspension
saying this one did a good job of
adjusting it so you don't feel like
you're being thrown out of a curve this
vehicle is anything but squishy he says
and even at the end of a long trip it
won't give you a backache Swami what the
hell flange Titan give me this is far so
dusky food all nourishments nonsuit so
come along with the many design options
several optional assists are offered to
make driving and parking the Micra
easier like a 360-degree camera an
emergency brake assist a lane departure
warning system and a blind-spot warning
system
[Music]
Micra has changed not only its exterior
but also the whole structure of its
interior
Ronnie likes the steering wheels
beautiful design saying it fits your
hands wonderfully and it's well cut
that's highlight number one is
highlighted highlight number two for
running is the interior color palette
which gives it a feel good ambience but
Ronny find something to complain about
the Sun Visor what was this I'm thinking
he wonders the visor is so big that it
can block your view of the road entirely
so you have to push it up against the
windshield
the interiors colorful fabrics and
quality materials give the car pep the
instruments are nicely arranged the
driver and front seat passenger sit
comfortably and well-designed seats with
plenty of room to move but in the rear
seat things are a bit cramped as in many
small cars plus the rear passengers have
to roll the windows down by hand all
around the back cedar isofix attach
points for child safety seats
[Music]
Plus intercourse
Ronnie sums up here is a compact 4
meters long gone is the cute exterior of
earlier models this generation version
won't be called a lady's car anymore
either
it's really well designed apart from the
Sun Visor Ronnie has no other complaints
nice wide open
[Music]
daring different distinctive after its
c4 cactus now cinta one is also given
the c3 a fleshy R design but will
potential customers like it
the c3 is an especially important model
for its maker accounting for one in five
sets one sold in Europe the air bumps
guarding the side doors are already
familiar from the cactus
but sandal or card says - eNOS Petrie
says the C threes curves and smooth
surfaces make it look the way around
peppermint drop feels on your tongue the
exterior design avoids edges and corners
but while easy on the eye it's far from
boring the accents on the fog lamps and
exterior mirrors match the color of the
roof the front takes its cue from Ronnie
SUV crossover models and boasts three
lamp units on each side the air bumps on
the doors are optional but they make a
big contribution to the C threes
conspicuous look
9 exterior colors and 3 more for the
roof provide a selection of 36 different
color combinations the c3 loses some
points with its trunk
whether loading or unloading you have to
heat your cargo over this tall trunk
sill and when you put the back seats
down the resulting surface has a big
bump not pretty and not practical we
test-drove the c3 with the most powerful
of the three gasoline engines available
the 1.2 liter 3-cylinder engine produces
81 kilowatts and a substantial 205
Newton meters of torque and that's at
just 1500 RPM our test car comes with a
top equipment package shine and the
price just under 18,000 euros in Germany
but then I don't know Tina says 81
kilowatts will take you down a country
road at a fast pace but the fun of
driving is told a bit by the loose
steering you have to turn the wheel
quite a bit before the car responds and
the manual 5-speed transmission responds
a bit slowly to Vega behind the sin line
a six-speed Automatic transmission
promises faster shifting although it's
available only in combination with the
most powerful engine the designers left
nothing to chance in the interior enos
notes everywhere inside components take
up the motif of the side door air bumps
the c3 s interior is similarly
unconventional while the competition is
working hard to make everything flow
smoothly around the driver here
everything is very angular with lots of
color variety and attention to detail
[Music]
where the see threes exterior is all
curves and smooth surfaces as eNOS the
interior straight lines and ninety
degree angles remind her of a cubicle
Swiss herb candy that gives driver and
passengers plenty of room to move
Vorenus the interior seems as if the
engineers constructed it around an
imaginary box among optional extras are
practical assists including a parking
aid a blind spot alert system and
traction control to reduce wheel
spinning penises you can connect your
cell phone with the car through the
central console operating unit the radio
can be controlled the old-fashioned way
with a knob to change the volume but
many other buttons have been eliminated
the air conditioning and heater can only
be operated via the touchscreen and
since the display is located rather low
down it definitely diverts your eyes
from the road monitors and diction
finestra's in non-vet Lane the car
itself however has its gaze firmly fixed
ahead and it can save images in case of
an accident
I know technical special in the Citroen
c3 is this dash cam says eNOS since when
calls it the connected cam and it's
integrated behind the mirror you can
take pictures or shoot short film clips
of the road ahead as you drive and then
share them with friends on the social
networks
[Music]
hey Gallup penis sums up part round
peppermint drop part herb candy cube sit
- on c3 is an interesting mixture that
will get attention on the road the c3
has also won the attention of a jury of
design experts this July the car will be
awarded the renowned red dot award
[Applause]
[Music]
Mercedes has given the AMG gla45 4matic
a facelift the restyled front section
and the new lip on the front spoiler
enhanced the aerodynamics packing 280
kilowatts of output and 475 Newton
meters of torque the AMG GLA is among
the highest performance cars in its
segment
it makes the dash to 100 km/h and a
swift 4.4 seconds
VW presents the second technology
generation of the e-golf the new
electric power unit now delivers 100
kilowatts of output increasing the cars
range from 190 to 300 kilometers the
Nili golf now also has better
acceleration and a higher top speed a
new assist function helps the driver to
adopt a more energy-saving driving style
prices for the new Eagle start at just
under 36,000 euros in Germany
by McLaren become with McLaren you get
exactly what you see says our car man
line hood a supercar with outstanding
performance room for two and to go wing
doors less space but more power so how
does the McLaren shape up in everyday
conditions my tuk
[Music]
the British have a long tradition of
motor racing and supercars and what
better example than McLaren its
Motorsports team has been a fixture on
the Formula One circuit since 1966 and
in 1993 McLaren also began making and
assembled sports cars its Formula One
R&D centre is just around the corner
from its commercial production facility
a proximity that the 650s spider
benefits from with brakes tear
technology onboard originally designed
by McLaren for Formula One the inside
rear wheel is slowed around churns
aligning the front of the car to the
apex of the curve that means the driver
can brake far later and accelerate
sooner the system was banned in Formula
One before it was even introduced
the color takes its name from the 650
horsepower generated by the engine which
translates into serious pickup in 2013
and one McLaren the first of three
successive engine of the Year awards so
for a piffling 255 thousand euros you
get road-going Formula One engineering
i'm sylva a supercar that accelerates
from 0 to 100 km/h in 3 seconds from 0
to 208 seconds and 0 to 326 seconds
didn't worry about city traffic but
that's no problem today thanks to the
7-speed dual-clutch transmission the
rear view to the right is impeded by the
thick B pillar but you do have the rear
view camera look [ __ ] em up the interior
is replete with leather and carbon fiber
[Music]
and if you can't get enough of the sound
of the v8 on the inside even with the
roof closed you can just pop down the
rear window
on the occupant safety front there's a
carbon-fiber monocoque another familiar
feature for motor racing and the British
engineers took a further cue from their
Formula One creations with a 650 s's air
brake rear spoiler it shifts up when the
brakes are applied to ensure maximum
downforce and stability during
acceleration it retracts automatically
thereby reducing air resistance it's
similar to the famous drag reduction
system or DRS used in Formula One
[Music]
demikhov inspire the spider does 330
kilometres an hour with the roof down
says Reinhold but at your destination
some of the times save driving will be
spent shopping because the trunk is only
big enough for a bit of hand luggage
[Music]
demand for SUVs continues unabated
nearly every major car maker maintains
their line of sports utility vehicle and
related products our car reviewer Iman
oo is taking another look at one of the
classics of the compact crossover
segment the Volkswagen Tiguan now and
its second generation our test car has a
2-liter 110 kilowatt
[Applause]
yeah Amana wall delicately describes the
test cars 110 kilowatts as unexcited the
specs say it will push the car from zero
to 100 kilometers an hour in 10 seconds
but it feels longer zynga SUVs are by no
means known for their fuel efficiency
even if the car maker rates consumption
at 5.7 liters per 100 kilometers had a
good 8.6 liters the tikka one we checked
out proved quite a bit thirstier he's
dustin oh god it occurs to Emanuele that
the longer he drives the more peculiar
the questions racing through his head
what for example does Tiguan actually
mean the first association he has is a
cross between a tiger and an iguana
but with those 110 kilowatts this is
mornig wanna than a tiger it can crawl
across the terrain at a leisurely pace
but when necessary it can take off on a
sprint a boffin snootiest kind of a
foolish fool
the name Tiguan really was concocted
from a combination of Tiger and iguana a
prominent German automotive magazine
asked its readers to vote on which name
they preferred for the new SUV Tiguan
secured 36 percent of the votes outdoing
alternative options such as Nanook Namib
rockton and some une petite Juan's basic
design concept emphasizes the practical
use of space bold horizontal contours
dominate the front rod structural lines
underline the car's sporty character
side skirting provides protection in
rough terrain and an off-road look beg
would command a while especially likes
the tikka Juan's versatility when it
comes to space if you need more legroom
and back just pull the lever under the
rear seats if you have no passengers but
lots of cargo to carry you can pull the
seat all the way forward to create more
space longer can't Bank on stefana the
seats stay up so whatever's behind them
will stay put even if you slam on the
brakes
that's what some coffee Lamas buy for
blender one in Coffee London
depending on how far forward or back the
rear seats are the cargo space ranges
between 520 and 615 litres folding the
seat down means a little over 1,000 650
liters so what key guides all these
tigers and iguanas can negotiate rugged
terrain pretty well Suzy Manawa just
like this test car thanks to its 4
motion all-wheel drive
switching to off-road mode activates a
range of assists one improves traction
on slippery driving surfaces another
allows the use of the engine for extra
braking on steep descents the off-road
mode handles uneven and muddy terrain
quite nicely
[Music]
the VW tiguan starts at just under 27
thousand euros in Germany but the
equipment included will only satisfy the
most Spartan standards adding just a few
options
swiftly hikes the price closer to 40
thousand the car we tested with
all-wheel drive and direct shift
transmission list for over 51,000 euros
yeah I'm summing up you manawa still
thinks the SUV he tested is definitely
more of an iguana than a tiger but he
could easily imagine that a stronger
engine version would put more Tiger back
into the Tiguan mia tiga - looking in t
one blinked
[Music]
every year vintage car fans and pundits
flock to essence trade fair center for
the techno classica last year crowds of
over 200,000 made it the world's most
popular vintage car and motorcycle fair
[Music]
the Volvo p1800 s was once driven by
Roger Moore and his TV role as the saint
and the techno classica was the perfect
spot for Volvo to celebrate its 90th
anniversary also on show was a 1933 P V
654 and those days Sweden's car market
was dominated by American models so
Volvo needed a large 6-cylinder car to
compete the party wouldn't be complete
without a Volvo 145 given the Swedish
car makers association with station
wagons
yeah my father this man's father used to
drive a red Volvo and was very happy
with it
[Music]
the PV 444 was nicknamed the hunchback
it's hard not to wax nostalgic
surrounded by so much history
thus aficionados grunt of Mr explains at
the car won the 1962 German Touring Car
Championship it was driven by Yosef
Mawson from Incheon Gladbach Aram a
coffee roasting house and he won in this
car with a 1.6 liter engine that was the
size class as well the next one was the
1.8 liter engine Yosef had to go up
against the Borg by disability' for the
time and he did it how about how - there
was a putt that's a shuffle Opel is
reviewing their tradition of large
sedans at the techno classica the
Admiral was opals flagship in the late
1930s yeah clothes idlers started out
with a 1951 capitaine he adjusted the
vowels for the first time when he was 12
or 13 he describes the sedan as the non
plus ultra for the time the first one
was launched on the company's 75th
anniversary so the engine had to put out
75 horsepower that was opals own 3.6
litre unit from the Blitz Michaelmas xt
time between gtpase on Brits and the 60s
the diplomat was a highly coveted luxury
sedan and it still is
embodying the 1970s concept of luxury is
the Opel senator doesn't sudden this
body expert grew up with the car he used
to see it everywhere parked along the
streets older gentleman like to drive it
he thought it was great and what's the
status symbol but he's more interested
in the old mechanics than the new modern
stuff a snake medium Oh Diana VB Noah a
total of nearly 70,000 senators rolled
off the production line this Opel
capitaine with gold-plated fittings is a
special edition it was the two millionth
car made by Opel and the only one of its
kind Opel had become the first European
car maker to pass that production
landmark also at the fair our vintage
car clubs from around the world
exhibiting their most prized specimens
and talking shop with other owners
[Music]
at the Porsche stand the carmaker is
observing the 40th anniversary of a 928
fastback coupe a it was made from 1977
to 95 and occupied the top of the range
who designed this Porsche fan Goethe
Weber describes it as a young man's
dream a superb car high quality in high
performance yet affordable the average
earner could buy a car like this he
praises the car to the sky saying the
engine ran smoothly and it was and still
is very fast this one-off Porsche 928
was a study for a four-seater and a gift
from the company's workers to the
legendary ferry Porsche to that side
Kluger explains the idea behind it was
to get more people into the car but
still marketed as a Porsche
it was a study but never went into
production they were trying out various
ways to increase profit as we could see
it's still around and it costs even more
now so de toilettes Vuitton was an
important factor in preserving and
increasing value is original components
Porsche for example has over 52,000
parts available for its past models that
makes it easier to repair and restore
classic cars and helps ensure that the
old masterpieces never lose their shine
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you